you
.
Stand by.
Good afternoon.
This meeting of the Huntsville City Council will come to order.
I am President Pro Tem Bill Kling and with me are Councilmembers David Little and Michelle Watkins.
The purpose of this special session is for the purpose of canvassing the returns of the municipal runoff election that was held on September 22nd.
I am now going to turn the program meeting over to the City Clerk for the counting of provisional ballots.
Good afternoon Council and to all joining online and in the Council chambers.
Good afternoon Councilmembers.
Today we will be counting the provisional ballots that require further review by the Board of Registrars.
Council there were seven provisional ballots and of those seven, five have been accepted to be counted towards our official results of the September 22nd runoff election.
I will now begin counting those ballots and I will announce each candidate.
Thank you.
Council I will pass the ballot down to you.
For our first ballot, Jenny Robinson.
For our second ballot, Jenny Robinson.
For our third ballot, Jenny Robinson.
For our fourth ballot, Jenny Robinson.
For our fourth ballot, Lilliana Pender and Council for your records, this ballot has been torn and we will have to manually load the results.
It will not feed in the DS 200 machine.
It will count.
It will when we update the official numbers that you see on the screen.
It is here present and he will update manually before I read the final results.
And for our fifth and final ballot, which this ballot council is also torn, we will load the results manually and it is Lilliana Pender.
And that will conclude the reading of all of our provisional ballots.
And at this time, we will allow our team to update the official election night reporting system.
And then I will read the final numbers into the record.
Council, while we wait on the election night reporting system to update, Councilman Kling asked me to explain this process.
And I think it's important to understand provisional ballots.
If they are accepted, it means that they voted in the precinct and it needed further review by the Board of Registrars.
Oftentimes, someone may be at the wrong precinct and those are rejected.
You must be in your correct precinct in order for your ballot to be cast.
And also, you could be missing an ID and you have an opportunity at a later date to present that to the Board of Registrars.
Also, if you vote absentee in my office, but because of mail or for whatever reason, your absentee ballot did not make it back in time.
You still have an opportunity for your ballot to be cast by voting provisional in the precinct.
And so we take time to work with the Board of Registrars to ensure that every vote counts and there is a thorough review before today's canvassing.
Councilman claims there anything else you wanted me to explain.
Okay.
Okay, we will wait on the system to update as we close the polls.
Thank you, Tom.
Before we get started, I do want to say to the Madison County staff, thank you to the Board of Registrars.
Thank you to our district, and our district, and our community, and our district, and our community.
Thank you to the RIT, probate judge, Frank barger and his staff, ES&S, and our circuit clerk for their support during this 2026 municipal election cycle.
It would not be possible without the collaboration.
that are absent on a well-deserved vacation.
Thank you and to the council for being here today
as we wrap up.
Our results are ready.
And at this time, council, for the record,
Liliana Pender received 47.64% with 3,436 votes.
Jenny Robinson, 52.36% with a total of 3,736 votes.
And at this time, council,
I will officially turn it over to you
for new business items for consideration.
Thank you. Thank you.
I might add for those who are in the council chambers,
the individual box totals are a point
on the billboard over there for your inspection.
Council members, is there a motion concerning
Okay.
Is there a motion concerning declaring
Jenny Robinson, district three, city council,
city of Huntsville elected to her position
for a term beginning November 2nd, 2026.
Move to approve.
Second.
Motion has been made and properly seconded.
Discussion.
All those in favor signify by saying aye.
Aye.
And the chair votes aye.
I hereby declare Jenny Robinson is the winner
of the district three city council race
of the city of Huntsville, Alabama.
If there's no other business, we're adjourned.
Thank you.